los héroes tras el mayor atentado en la
historia reciente de eeuu así es como se
reconoce a los 750 bomberos de nueva
york que acudieron al instante de
conocerse el ataque a las torres gemelas
la mitad de ellos nunca regresó
el 11 de septiembre respondimos a las
torres gemelas no teníamos idea de
cuántas personas había realmente en las
torres la estimación era entre 25.000 y
50.000
750 miembros del departamento
respondieron su trabajo consistía en
evacuar al mayor número de personas
posibles y evacuamos a miles pero antes
de que pudiéramos sacar a todos de ese
edificio se nos acabó el tiempo y 343 de
nuestros integrantes murieron
robos las labores de búsqueda se
extendieron hasta mayo de 2002 la
exposición de los sobrevivientes a los
gases tóxicos que se desprendían de los
escombros causó diversas enfermedades
a la larga mortales otros 250 bomberos
murieron
los bomberos hacen un juramento cuando
ingresan al departamento como y yo hace
casi 52 años para proteger la vida y la
propiedad y esto es lo que nuestros
bomberos hicieron inicialmente y después
de que se derrumbaron los edificios
todavía teníamos la esperanza de
rescatar a las personas que habían
sobrevivido al colapso y nuestros
bomberos inmediatamente se pusieron a
trabajar a norman versiones de walt to
work a un 20 años después no hay un día
en que el cuerpo de bomberos no recuerde
lo vivido ese 11 de septiembre ahora los
miembros más recientes del equipo muchos
quienes incluso no habían nacido a la
fecha se les enseña la importancia de
ese día que marcó en dos la historia del
cuerpo de bomberos neoyorquinos y la del
mundo entero